last night we expected what would happen
it would be the seattle seahawks losing
or winning excuse me over the
philadelphia eagles
although they didn't cover to the
chagrin of the person who put 500 000
on the seahawks giving six and a half
points proving yet again
don't bet and i know people say well if
you're going to bet 500 000
that means you got plenty more out there
to lose it's still 500
000 i don't care how much money you
have if you lose half a million
after tax dollars that hurts
not that i've ever done it or ever
planned to
or ever could get clearance from my wife
just
to to to bet 500 much less 5
000. it hurts i don't care if you're
warren buffett
losing 500 000 would have to hurt badly
especially the way
that that person lost it last night
yeah my hopefully they had bets on some
other games but
yeah the way it happened with the the
late touchdown and the two-point
conversion i mean come on you didn't
expect that to happen they were probably
already
counting their money and and then oh my
gosh we didn't cover there but hopefully
there were other bets to help make up
for that 500
000 loss yeah hey who knows maybe the
person's been on a hot streak and the
500 000 is just a rare loss and all the
others
were winners dk metcalf big winner with
a career high 177 yards against the
philadelphia eagles he had 160 against
him in the playoff win last year he's
extra motivated when he plays the eagles
because they're one of the teams that
passed on him just seven spots before he
was picked
and they drafted a receiver jj ortega
white side so
extra motivation for dk metcalf here he
is on making the eagles pay
for passing on him
okay let's move on here's pete carroll
maybe we have that
pete carroll from today talking about
the comment
that was made by jim schwartz the eagles
defensive coordinator
to dk metcalf before the game apparently
it was intended by schwartz to be a
compliment
comparing metcalf to calvin johnson who
played for jim schwartz
metcalf took it as shade here's pete
carroll
weighing in on the exchange between
schwartz and metcalf
megatron's kind of a thing of the past
you know not many people know about that
i mean if he had a call says something
referred to him like the mandalorian
you know i think it'd be a little more
appropriate but
i wouldn't mind calling dk mandalorian
anytime he wants
pete carroll would later post the
graphic of uh dk metcalf with the
mandalorian helmet
on on his head but look i i even
and sims and i argued about this today
because sims thought i was being too
hard on schwartz
because schwartz apparently was trying
to compliment dk metcalf
when you know that a guy's already wired
to have a chip on his shoulder
he's going to process everything you say
in a way
that strengthens that feeling he's not
going to let himself
go soft because somebody's coming over
and paying him a compliment he's going
to do the michael jordan thing and he's
going to turn
any statement that's made into more of a
disc to get him even more motivated
to go out and kick your butt so don't
even try
would be my advice to any coach from any
opposing team
that thinks he's going to say something
before a game to get dk metcalf to be
less motivated shereen
or frankly mike any player we know that
players use
everything and anything to motivate
themselves and sometimes it's
silly it's absolutely stupid stuff that
they do to motivate them
later in the show we're going to talk
about motivation for debo samuel
probably but
these players look for motivation
especially these diva receivers that
they look for any kind of chip on the
shoulder that they can have to go into a
game and and really play
well and he did it and he's going to use
the motivation probably from now on
against the eagles kind of like randy
moss did against the cowboys for years
and years and years and they regretted
they didn't draft
randy moss and he kept using that as
motivation against the cowboys and i'm
sure dk metcalf will continue to do that
against the eagles if not against every
other team that he plays all he needs is
one little comment and that's going to
set him off obviously
one of the things that helps make
receivers great
not being taken in round one being
passed over multiple times
you do get that chip on your shoulder
and it stays with you whether it's
michael thomas
chase claypool this year who was the
11th receiver off the board are you
kidding me
and also dk metcalf the last player
taken in round two
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports